hey everybody its charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see Black Panther
there's actually a pretty solid
connection to the Captain Marvel movie
in it through an Easter egg but they
slipped it in pretty slightly so you may
not have realized it till you are
walking out of the theater but it also
implies much larger goings on behind the
scenes in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
respective to the Coulson character so
I'll explain what it all means if you're
finding me for the first time we do
Marvel every week infinity Wars coming
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and just careful for spoilers for
Black Panther if you haven't seen it yet
so recently all the Black Panther actors
are doing press junkets talking about
the movie martin freeman revealed that
he's scheduled to appear in multiple
future marvel movies now we have
infinity war coming up in a couple
months we can safely assume that he
probably pops up somewhere there because
of the black panther connection now then
we have Captain Marvel in the spring of
next year which kind of takes the black
panther a really spot in 2019
then Avengers for the Captain Marvel
connection came when Sheree was reading
off Everett Ross's personal history
inside her lab she says he's a former
Air Force pilot they paid that off later
when she had him remote pilot that
shuttle and take out all those vibranium
weapon shipments towards the end of the
film but Martin Freeman was about 46 in
real life when they shot this movie so
assuming that Everett Ross is a similar
age he would have been in his mid to
late 20s when he was an Air Force pilot
in his prime there been a couple Captain
Marvel pictures from behind the scenes
they released we talked about the green
costume that she's wearing made to look
like the original marvel's Kree costume
she has the Rachel haircut from the
friends TV show and we can actually use
that to date Captain Marvel because they
say the movie happens during the 90s but
they didn't say early 90s mid late 90s
the brilliant thing about giving her
that Rachel haircut is that one is kind
of funny but - it helps date her more
specifically during the 90s because
Jennifer Aniston did not have that
haircut before 1995 meaning the Captain
Marvel takes place between 1995 and 1999
during that period Everett Ross would
have been in his mid to late 20s so he
and Carol Danvers would have both been
Air Force pilots around the same time so
it sounds like he will actually
no Captain Marvel when she comes back
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe when
she shows up at the end of infinity war
maybe they film a flashback with Martin
Freeman but this is where we get to the
Coulson of it all because what was
Coulson early in phase 1 he was sort of
that office space type guy that would
pop up in everybody's movies what about
the whole cover story that it's a
bodyguard
he's my body I mean is that that's kind
of flimsy I think this isn't my first
rodeo mr. stark just stick to the
official statement and soon this will
all be behind you he would be used for a
comedy like oh I can't believe they're
making me deal with this crap from
another planet like you were made to
laugh at the odd couple that he was with
Thor in the Thor movie and then he would
just pop up me to serve as the
connective tissue between the movies
till we got to a big Avengers team-up
and you brought Nick Fury back because
initially his character wasn't really a
character he was just the shield guy and
they kept using him because they like
Clark gray and he was not expensive to
hire the way that samuel l.jackson was
samuel l.jackson can sometimes command
upwards of 20 million dollars for movies
but either way back during phase 1 phase
2 Marvel was pinching pennies until they
got out from under Isaac Perlmutter
Stumm now they pay the actors more money
they spend more money on amenities
things that they didn't do before so
them giving Martin Freeman's Everett
Ross this Air Force backstory just
implies another you know nail on the
coffin that he's unofficially replaced
Coulson in the MCU is that office space
guy who just pops up in everyone's
movies and serves as the connective
tissue when he was asked during Avengers
age of Ultron if the Avengers would ever
learn that Coulson was still alive
because by that time we'd already gotten
the shield TV show so he would brought
back to life we got the whole Tahiti
explainer we didn't explain that in the
movie universe
Coulson's death was used as this big
moment to catalyze the Avengers and to
bring him back will completely undercut
that moment so he said that in his mind
Coulson was supposed to be dead and he
would stay that way in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe meaning that they
would never learn that he was still
alive although there there was a bit of
a backdoor explainer on a shield episode
where lady SIF learned that he was alive
she called him son of Cole and it was
implied that she would eventually tell
Thor that he was still alive because she
knew about his connection with the
Avengers
take that easter egg for what you will
but I will say that when it comes to
movies acknowledging stuff that happens
on the TV shows the people that wrote
Captain America Civil War and were
involved in the writing of infinity war
said that they don't watch the Marvel TV
shows like they literally don't watch
them on television so they have no idea
what's going on so the odds of them
referencing anything that's happening on
TV in the movies is close to zero so
that doesn't mean that Coulson's gone
forever in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it just means that Marvel Studios
doesn't want to deal with Marvel
television like they just don't want to
worry about what they're doing like make
your TV shows we'll make our movies and
we're not gonna force all of our writers
to watch every single hour of television
that you guys have been making so that's
not that out of hate it's not like Kevin
Feige is purposefully trying to rope off
the Marvel television universe like I
don't want to have any of that mixing
with my movies it's mostly done for the
audience members that are going to see
the movies so that it's not required to
them to watch all the TV shows before
they watch the movies that's why can
seem sometimes like the plot is
relatively simple
that's why Black Panther reads a little
bit like The Lion King which is
basically an adaptation of Hamlet if you
guys didn't know the Lion King is
basically Hamlet Black Panther does a
little bit of hamlet I'll be with a
couple twists talked about funny Easter
eggs for that friends TV show to Everett
Ross himself was created by Christopher
priest during his Marvel nights run
Christopher priest great black panther
writer but he said that he created him
specifically to have a personality based
on that of Chandler Bing from the
friends TV show because he debuted in
1998 while the friends TV show was
blowing up and for a lot of you that are
asking if he's related to Thunderbolt
Ross he specifically stated that the
name Everett Ross was an homage to Alex
P Keaton from family ties Michael J Fox
is character so originally he was just
created as an audience surrogate that
was a way in for people not familiar
with Black Panthers character his
traditions the people of Wakanda they
kind of used him that way during the
Black Panther movie too albeit they
toned down the Chandler being quite a
bit but the next time you go to see
Black Panther think about Chandler Bing
when Everett Ross is on screen so even
though he and Everett Ross appeared
during civil war there's no implied
relationship between those characters
it's really just like a fan thing like
well they have the same last name maybe
they're related but in the comics
Christopher priest said that he wasn't
thinking of Thunderbolt Ross when he
created the character also there's been
a lot of talk about Black Panther - they
haven't officially confirmed it yet they
haven't even hired Ryan Coogler for the
second movie they didn't lock him down
for that so they're gonna have to pay a
ton of money the same thing happened
with Wonder Woman and patty Jenkins they
only hired her for one film so when it
came time to do the second film she got
a ton of extra money so you got to give
mad props to Ryan Coogler because he is
gonna make Bank when it comes time to
make that sequel but because Everett
Ross is such a core Black Panther
character I think we can assume that
he's going to come back in some form or
another but what's gonna happen next is
is because Black Panther is officially
out they're gonna start dropping some
more infinity Wars soon so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm not expecting another really big
trailer until March Madness that's
usually like a really big sporting event
where everybody drops a lot of footage
so Deadpool to everything leave all your
bonus video requests for concepts or
comic book things specific to the Marvel
Universe or anything else that you guys
want me to do congratulations to the
latest Infinity Gauntlet giveaway winner
SB shrap please private message me so I
can get your contact details the Marvel
giveaway is for those replicas of the
Infinity Gauntlet I'll name a new winner
when I post new Marvel so click here for
all my Black Panther Easter eggs and
click here for my post credits scene
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]